i
a
[Música]
simplemente hace varias semanas el
llamado pase de movilidad como una forma
de incentivar a las personas que no se
han vacunado el nadado y que se
encuentran rezagadas a hacerlo al
ofrecer una serie de privilegios a
aquellas personas que han completado su
sistema de inoculación con dos dosis y
que han transcurrido ya el periodo para
desarrollar la inmunidad necesarias en
un principio privilegiaba el movimiento
entre ciertas zonas en cuarentena o no
ahora permite por ejemplo a las personas
que cuentan con este pase comer en el
interior de los restaurantes y también a
foros más masivos en el caso de
conciertos teatros espectáculos u otros
para las personas que llegan fuera del
país este pase de movilidad se convierte
en un pasaporte sanitario que tiene que
ser homologado con las vacunas que
recibieron en el exterior y también se
les toma la temperatura al llegar al
país si no se cuenta con este paso
aparte de sanitario tienen que pasar una
cuarentena en unas residencias
sanitarias designadas por el gobierno y
bajo su propio costo
[Música]
uruguay se cuenta con un pasaporte
sanitario que le permite a sus
ciudadanos certificar su vacunación
contra el cob y 19 esto se realiza por
medio de una aplicación donde el
ministerio de salud pública conecta con
él y ata travel pass entretanto a partir
del primero de septiembre se abrirán las
fronteras para los extranjeros que
tengan propiedades en el país y a partir
del primero de noviembre para todos los
extranjeros en ambos casos deben de las
personas estar completamente inmunizados
contra el cob y 19 para facilitar su
ingreso en el ministerio de salud
pública en su página web también tiene
donde completar la información y obtener
allí un denominado pasaporte sanitario
las autoridades de uruguay anunciaron
que en los próximos días la aplicación
tendrá una nueva versión denominada
pasaporte wii y está juntará la
información tanto de uruguayos como de
extranjeros y prometen que será más
completa incluso que él ya está travel
paz
por otra parte el gobierno uruguayo
volvió a conectar internacionalmente por
vía aérea volvieron las conexiones con
eeuu y en septiembre será el país de
latinoamérica con mayor conexión con
europa
con el avance de la vacunación contra
kobe 19 en el mundo comienzan a aparecer
a implementarse diferentes versiones de
pases o pasaportes sanitarios en
argentina hubo algunas aproximaciones el
distrito más poblado del país la
provincia de buenos aires decidió hacia
fines de julio una ampliación de aforo
para bares y restaurantes para personas
vacunadas con al menos una dosis pero
luego en agosto eligió plegarse una
ampliación general implementada a nivel
nacional que no distingue entre personas
vacunadas y no vacunadas otras
provincias también evaluaron o evalúan
la posibilidad de que los vacunados
puedan llegar a tener mayor acceso en
ciertos contextos en algunos casos se
llegó a poner en práctica de todos modos
la posibilidad de implementar algún tipo
de pase sanitario a mayor escala sigue
siendo difícil en el país porque según
los datos oficiales todavía falta
vacunar con primera dosis a cerca del 40
por ciento de la población
[Música]